[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que c'est une liste indépendante
et l'intérêt communal c'est une liste
représentant toutes les sensibilités et
tous les quartiers
et puis c'est aussi une liste
représentant la diversité du en cours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors le point fort de notre programme
ce soir 84 engagement 84 engagements qui
sont tous documenté qui sont tous
réalisable et qui sont tous mesurables
ils sont répartis en cinq grands thèmes
le carreau de vie l'écologie l'animation
de la ville la vie municipale
la jeunesse et les seniors et parmi ces
84 engagement on a quelques projets
forts comme d'hab' avec la construction
d'une minicentrale qui est synonyme de
maîtrise des approvisionnements circuits
courts et en produits bio également pour
permettre une plante et son goku puis
celle de l'ensemble de nos écoliers
vous avez également le centre aquatique
on souhaiterait construire un nouveau
centre aquatique dans le quartier dit
des savoirs en remplacement de la
piscine actuelle qui est complètement
sous dimensionné la mise en place aussi
de conseils de quartier parce que c'est
le seul moyen pour nous d'avoir un lien
direct avec le quartier est de pouvoir
discuter en allemand de tous les projets
qui concernent les habitants de chaque
quartier
et puis également dans notre projet qui
concerne le personnel communal avec la
construction d'un nouveau centre
technique municipal qui s'endorment
haute qualité en ville environnementales
et qui permettra une réduction des
émissions de co2 des activités
municipales
[Applaudissements]
alors allez directement lié à la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons notre
équipe a continué à travailler pendant
sept heures du confinement et il nous
est apparu important que les premières
mesures que nous prendrions serait la
destination des familles ou courtoise
alors la première chose qu'on ferait
c'est mettre en place des programmes de
soutien scolaire pendant cet été
et puis les activités ludiques paf avec
cet été se passe de manière la plus
agréable possible pour les pour les
familles lui encourt 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]